all right movies at the tin roof san
diego make some noise for kevin smith
and mark bernard
it's time for batman beyond
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to a very special edition of fat
man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernardin hey
all right kids uh for everyone listening
at home or watching live and if you're
watching at home and you're like oh man
the [ __ ] stream
is not smooth that's because every
[ __ ] in the world is here and
they're using the internet not here for
us here in san diego comic-con so we're
hoping to stay online if we get dropped
off uh josh is shooting the whole show
so we'll upload everything later on but
fingers crossed we get to stay online um
that being said just to take care of the
technical [ __ ]
uh we
are at the movies pop-up here at the tin
roof inn in san diego
uh
for san diego comic-con 22
the first comic-con in the summer that
we've been able to do in three years put
your hands together so the folks at home
know you're real
[Applause]
it took me so long to spit that out
because i'm incredibly blazed right now
i had a i had a very long day yeah go
figure you could probably smell it from
here i was uh i had a pretty busy day
and then uh when i finished before we
were uh gonna do this i was like oh i'm
gonna smoke all the weeds and uh i did
because this show is always like ah
like i don't have to worry about the
show i was talking to mark before we
went up i was like even if i drop the
ball and i will mark
can pick it up and [ __ ] run with it
one of my favorite parts of the show
is mark and that's saying a lot because
i'm a huge kevin smith fan and [ __ ]
um so i was looking forward to this
because uh today i did two back-to-back
hall h panels i was there for one of
them you went to one of them i did uh we
did a masters of the universe a 40th
anniversary panel that's the one and
then uh right after that i i moderated
the shatner on shatner panel uh so
[ __ ] with two whole h panels back to
back i felt like chris hardwick circa
2016 man like i felt like holy [ __ ] this
is what it was like to be hardwick back
and like ice your your vocal chords and
like
leave the stage and then you come back
to the same stage for the next panel um
but today was for me of all the con days
the the quote-unquote toughest and it's
not really even that hard but just in
terms of process of elimination every
other day requires me to just go out
there and talk about kevin smith's [ __ ]
um today required me to go talk about
other people's [ __ ] and that's always
nerve-wracking in case like you [ __ ] up
or something so i was i'm happy i did
them uh i'm happy they're in the rear
view now because i don't have to worry
about them anymore now it's just [ __ ]
all downhill for me man it's smooth
sailing and not in a bad way like it's
all downhill like every i could be on
autopilot for the rest of this [ __ ]
because it just requires me to be kevin
smith and i could do that in my [ __ ]
sleep
so i was looking forward to this moment
and i i might have
i think it's
clear i smoked too much upstairs so no
you're doing great yeah you're doing
great you may have to take over the
[ __ ] show for a little while yeah
just slides off
truly i i don't know it was weird i was
just on stage with like a [ __ ] icon
like
shatner is 91 years old man
[ __ ] like laid the track for
like pop culture you know he went to
like some of the first cons and stuff
like that
and
you know i got to tell a story that i've
been waiting to tell
for a while i don't think i got to tell
it anyplace else but we finally
announced
that william shatner joined the cast of
masters of the universe revolutions
[Music]
absolute huge get for us and stuff um
we've recorded with him we recorded
everything already
and i told the story on the panel and i
got to tell it right in front of him and
it was [ __ ] darling um you know you
recorded the voices well in advance for
these things so we've got most of the
recording done his is completely
finished i can't say what character he's
going to play so i'm going to keep it
vague
so he comes in to do his performance and
like you know again dude's 91 but he
doesn't have somebody bring him there he
[ __ ] shows up in his own hot rod and
[ __ ]
he didn't ride a horse no but no he it
would have been not surprising if he did
because he's a huge horse fanatic and
stuff um today on the panel he talked
about
i want i want to say dressage but if i
do he'll be like you're an idiot kevin
uh it was called something else about
horses that can't turn [ __ ] like that i
i think
was i right yeah not corsage
i said now you're [ __ ] me up um
oh yeah i lost it it is dressage yeah
you killed it man and as high as i
thought man [ __ ] a
you found it i'm still with us so you
know uh when we were doing the recording
for him
um i was on a laptop because you don't
put people in rooms together anymore
because of covet and stuff so there's
one person that goes to the location the
studio where they're on mic and then a
bunch of us are on zoom including
colette who's our animation the the
performance director
she directs everybody she's been doing
it for years she's amazing i get to come
along because i was a showrunner and
stuff and i you know they tell me i have
directed from time to time so i was like
maybe i can you know throw in when
needed and blah blah blah and also like
some cats said yes to the show because
they expect you're going to be there and
if you're not there it'd be bad so kevin
smith ball tickle a little bit man hey
man thanks for doing it that kind of
[ __ ]
so i'm there for every recording session
and periodically like i'll be like can
we grab a reading like this i'm looking
for something a little more blah blah
so we're recording with uh william
shatner and we are like maybe one take
in
and he's
looking at the script and kind of going
through and reading it and i you know
colette was in charge but i kind of
jumped the gun because he did this
delivery and i was like bill can we can
we grab you know the next one you do it
can you do it like super emphatically
like almost like you're mad
any [ __ ] i'm on zoom and i'm on my
laptop in my in my house my wife is like
sitting over on the couch reading a
[ __ ] book not involved but we're in
the same room together alone that's the
key to marriage
so i'm on the screen and talking and i
said can we just grab one like a little
more emphatically when he do it
and
this was the counter direction that
william shatner gave to me he goes kevin
kevin kevin
in a moment you will have the pleasure
of directing me
right now i'm just reading your script
and i was like okay and so uh jennifer
my wife is off to the side she puts her
book down
and she looks at me and [ __ ] and i put
it on mute and i'm like what and she's
like it took captain kirk to get silent
bob to shut the [ __ ] up nice
[Applause]
so it was uh [ __ ] trippy man doing
the panel it was pretty weird so yeah he
came up and uh for the motu panel to say
that hey i'm on the show and then i got
to moderate his panel afterwards but it
was lovely man it was lovely being back
in hall age lovely being on the con
floor
on the con floor lionsgate is releasing
clerks three they built a uh
environment where you can go stand
behind the counter and take pictures and
[ __ ] like that so i went to see that
this morning looks phenomenal they're
giving out these cool ass quick stop
bags they look like this
you got one
[ __ ] you're lucky man because they
did 4 000 yesterday and they gave them
out in like a half an hour
and then they did another 4 000 today
and they're just [ __ ] gone they also
do like a hundred of the posters the con
exclusive poster we have
so i got to do that this morning yo can
i have one of those though the bags yeah
i'll get you i know a guy i mean that's
why i'm asking
he's like i like a bag but i don't want
to wait in line i can't make much happen
in this life anymore but if it's a clerk
or a quick stop thing i'm your [ __ ]
man man
um so yeah it was just a long day and
the rest of the days are me doing press
for clerks 3 or going to do a hall h
panel on saturday or doing shows here
but today was the one day that was
nerve-wracking and when i looked at the
schedule i was like if i could just get
to
batman beyond like that'll be a relief
so it's such a relief [ __ ] being here
with you at fat man
[Music]
such a joy
has everyone [ __ ] had a good time at
comic-con so far
[Applause]
for a second i thought you were ending
the show yeah i was like goodbye every
time tonight peace like oh [ __ ] that was
fast we'll go a little bit longer um it
was so lovely to [ __ ] be back in the
environment and i'm sure
you know i experience a different
comic-con than most folks i know a lot
of people have to deal with lines and
and stuff like that um i've i didn't
meet anybody
who was
adversely affected by the line attitude
wise like nobody like oh
you don't know i had to wait in a
[ __ ] like the moment people come in
they're just so [ __ ] delighted to be
on the floor number one like because you
get to see [ __ ] number two
environmentally like the air
conditioning is pretty nice although
for those at home i know i felt bad i
was reading the news at one point today
and they're talking about the heat waves
across the [ __ ] nation
but i was sitting at my hotel with a
huge [ __ ] breeze coming in and i was
like i got to put on a sweater
this is [ __ ] nice down here man i
mean but it's still a bit humid though
was there i didn't feel i mean you're
talking to a guy i've come from jersey
man i know from humidity this is nothing
all right i was just sweating that's all
i was saying
what have you done today what were you
you had panels i had panels i was on
there were lines that i stood in to get
my fancy ass like look at me i got facts
yeah for those at home uh this is this
was the new wrinkle this year for the
con uh you need this
to get anywhere near the floor and this
is predicated on the vex the the right
you need this needed a mask which made
me feel so much better about it than i
ordinarily because there's a lot of
[ __ ] people here like it's it feels
like it's still a bit less than than
previous years
but it's like 80 or 90 000 people 135
000 really yeah all weekend long they
sold 135 000 sold out that was their cap
so they're sold out which is awesome to
see it come back so strong so once again
my numbers are off
a little bit thank you um but yeah i had
a couple panels to do i you know i had a
tequila lunch which was lovely you guys
have you had just tequila for lunch
before
like
i've been living my life wrong
apparently it makes the day fly by i
thought it was like a restaurant you
were like i went to tequila lunch you
just literally drank tequila for lunch i
did yeah
yeah
i got behind that i generally smoked my
lunch so
i don't regret my decision at all um
and then and then had another panel at 5
30 and the panels were it's interesting
being back in those rooms it's
interesting back with those people
because the thing that i miss about
comic con and i think a lot of us have
is a community that you have when you're
here
because we're all here because we love a
thing right whether that thing is star
wars or star trek or superheroes or
outlander or what we do in the shadows
or bob's burgers
we all showed up because of that love
the love is what draws us like moths to
a flame and to be back in these rooms
with people who came because they love a
thing you know i've spent a lot of time
on zoom the last three years and the
thing that you miss on zoom like it's
great i get to talk to people i get to
work it's lovely
i don't get to accidentally run into
people who i would ordinarily never meet
and find that they would be my best
friend if they weren't so weird
because we're all a little [ __ ] weird
but the the accidental joys you get at
comic-con are unlike any place else in
the world because you never know who
you're going to meet but that person is
going to love a thing as much as you
love your thing and that's just it's the
most beautiful place other than like
maui but
i i i didn't know how much i missed
until i got here and got a taste again
so good to be back what was the your
favorite thing that you did today and
while you asked that um while you
answered i'm gonna go
close this thing behind us because
everybody just keeps staring at us from
outside i feel like we're on the [ __ ]
today show and it's really unnerving so
tell them yeah jc banff man will you
[ __ ] put that thing up just slide it
over
just a little bit otherwise there's a
bazillion selfies of my fat ass back
and the lady outside is like i think
they're talking about me yes
[ __ ] stop taking a picture of me
from behind
aye poppy
um
what's the coolest thing i saw today
yeah dolph [ __ ] lundgren yeah was the
coolest thing i saw today he was on the
uh masters universe 40th anniversary
panel and like you know i was doing the
intro they wrote down a bunch of stuff
like you know oh the expendables uh
[ __ ] rocky iv but the the thing that
i [ __ ] bumped into and i was like
wait did i read this correctly it was
like and a chemical engineer
like apparently he's a [ __ ] chemical
engineer did you ever hear the story i
think we might have told him a podcast
before about the there was a bunch of
thieves who broke into a house in sweden
or whatever and they're doing their
thing they're going through the rooms
and they're taking the jewelry they're
taking the this they're taking the
expensive stuff and they get to the
master bedroom and then they see a
picture on the dresser of dolph lundgren
and his wife
and then they're like
put everything back
we're not taking it because not only is
he a [ __ ] like doctor of chemical
engineering he's got nine black belts
and a bunch of [ __ ] he's ivan drago he
will kick your ass from here to sunday
and everybody knows it they're like nope
all of it back all of it back hey hans
don't [ __ ] put [ __ ] back
hans
we had a [ __ ] racially profile man
um i saw here the thing coolest thing i
saw when i was on the floor today was a
gigantic art
support a portrait i i don't i don't
know it was kind of put together by a
bunch of different pieces but it was
hong kong phooey
wow [ __ ] life size it was like five
foot tall and i was like i never i was
sitting there going like i didn't
realize how much i needed this until
right now
but i was able to [ __ ] walk away you
didn't buy it well i'm just if it's
there at the end of con i might be like
all right let's haggle let's hack you're
gonna do your sunday sweep like hey
listen 50 you don't want to put that
back in the van let me just buy that for
you exactly and they'll be like didn't
you make clerks i'm like that's why i'm
trying to get a deal
all that money's gone
um what are you most looking forward to
i i i the marvel panel
has all of my interests and i'm going to
watch it from
like backstage because my panel is right
after the marvel panel in hall h can i
come [ __ ] yeah man sweet because that's
what i'm looking forward to that i'm
never going to get into that room for
that that panel yeah yeah because i
think we're going to see some some
wakanda [ __ ] you think so yeah
i think so what else would we see
um well they just started shooting iron
hearts when you keep talking they're
still looking at me go
go um they just started shooting well
they've been shooting the marvel so we
could see some of that um there's a
bunch of animation stuff what i don't
feel much better about that
this is like the best episode of the odd
couple
where you're just like felix they're
watching a
oh it's shower man everybody the
premiere of batman at san diego give it
up for jc
[Applause]
[Music]
i i think i'm gonna get in trouble
because the entirety of the internet
right now is freaking out that you guys
switched sides
i i knew something was wrong
like something about it i was just like
something's [ __ ] up maybe i'm high
we're just in the wrong chair
and
everything about this is backwards i
have the power yeah
it's also why
you're signing adora and mark is signing
tons of funko pops i see yeah maybe when
we do the news we'll swap we'll switch
seats oh yeah better when we have to to
throw to the bluetooth ad about making
dicks bigger
we'll stand up and we'll swap
talk about nuts so it'll be like a
metaphor right
just by standing standing we're getting
uh
we might as well welcome the sponsor now
so we can get on to other things kids
tonight's episode
uh
it's it's
yeah you can bring it in thank you will
wilkins everybody
[Applause]
nice
little bane off mike
um
tonight's sponsor uh ladies and
gentlemen for this edition of special
comic-con edition of fat man beyond uh
are the good folks at blue chew ladies
and gentlemen give it up for blue chew
give it up and get it up
now some of you are like what did we
applaud for well tell them mark what
blue chew is okay hold on which one of
the intros do you want to do because
they gave us two
we could do guys it's time to bring that
summer heat into the bedroom
or
the temperatures aren't the only thing
that's rising this summer
i won the last one
number two
b all right
uh what what voice should i use should i
use like like
jamaican
because he's so well known for his
jamaican accent well i did it once
before do you have a character do you
have anybody that you do oh the judge
the judge kevin i don't have a character
because i don't have any lines yes
fair enough
one day one no i don't want him now now
[ __ ] it i don't want your pity lines
all right i'll throw away that script i
was writing for mark to be the lead in
yeah oh the mark odyssey well hello
jason muse
uh all right let's figure this out
sounds like you've seen a kevin smith
movie or two
temperatures aren't the only thing
that's rising this summer that's right
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
guys confidence can take you far in life
it can also help you in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate that's where bluetooth
comes in it's a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets at a fraction of the
cost you can take them any time day or
night so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign up at bluetooth
i'm starting to do the like the job
you're going super fast
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online so no embarrassing
visits to a doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy and their tablets are made in
the good old usma patriot brand dick
bills and prepared and shipped direct to
your door in a discreet package do you
have any uh endorsement or
personalization you'd like to add
um
i mean i i can't beat their copy here
i'll try
um
you know it's hard
waiting in line at comic-con you know
what's harder your dick on blue chew
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use the promo
code fat mana checkout just pay five
dollar shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code fatman to receive your first
month free
there you go
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
that gets the sober thing safety
information
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
this podcast from thank you
thank the good folks of blue for not
only sponsoring this podcast but
offering free drugs on the internet give
it up for him ladies and gentlemen blue
chew
is your sponsor this evening
[Applause]
uh okay we've got the ads out of the way
so what shall we talk about first is
there news there is some news but i did
want to talk just a little bit because
we haven't been able to speak since the
finale of ms marvel oh [ __ ] yeah all
right let's talk about miss marvel how
many people here watch miss marvel
good nerds good night how many uh people
here have not yet watched ms marvel put
your hands together real quick
we're gonna spoil a little bit kids but
hopefully
at the end of it you're gonna want to
watch it a little bit more um we've
talked about it for a few weeks in a row
this show absolutely stuck the landing
the the final episode of [ __ ] the final
three episodes were so incredibly
emotionally satisfying uh dramatically
satisfying uh they did storytelling with
characters and culture that i'm not
achingly overly familiar with so all of
it was a new adventure
um the partition it was a history lesson
i think you were the one that mentioned
uh
like they're kind of doing what watchmen
did for tulsa or tulsa like introducing
a bunch that's not my history so i
didn't know that to some actual history
some heartbreaking history that happened
tying the main character's secret origin
into her own life in some weird way
um in a perfectly poetic and kind of
well-written way a dazzlingly directed
[ __ ] show
that
like when i i'm working on something now
where i'm supposed to direct it not this
thing i love for me but this other thing
that i'm writing for uh some other place
and i'm writing it with my kid and we
were talking about uh ms marvel i was
like you gotta watch this [ __ ] show i
said the directors of this show i i wish
they would do the show that we're doing
she's like you're supposed to direct the
show we're doing i was like i'll destroy
that [ __ ] show we should hand it over
to very talented cats like these are the
same two filmmakers making batgirl fight
correct no cr if i heard understand
correctly um
the show
made me the fact that i had never been a
teenage girl
try as i might it was just so damn
enjoyable her performance is magical
she's a [ __ ] star her and her mother
together yeah i would watch that show
and she don't even have to be a [ __ ]
hero they're dynamic they were so
[ __ ] charming um but that powerhouse
of an ending
was incredibly emotional before you get
to you know the [ __ ] moment when
uh i mean again spoilers if you haven't
seen this close your ears but come on
it's been all over the internet somebody
[ __ ] finally mentioned the word
mutant
yes
that her powers do not come from the
bangle they don't come from within per
se it's that and i think her little
science buddy says there's a mutation in
your genes that are giving you these
powers and then so satisfyingly a little
glisten
[Music]
um yeah it was interesting uh some cats
online got upset because they were like
hey man she's an inhuman she can't be a
mutant don't make her part of the x-men
and i was trying to follow the logic
like
why one would feel
passionately versus the other knowing
that marvel in the movies takes some of
their stuff and remixes it to do what
they want versus what it was in the
comic book page and the common consensus
i saw from a lot of people was like if
she's an inhuman she's the star of the
inhumans
if she's an x-men
she's getting in line behind wolverine
and all the x-men their fear is that the
character
will like they're using her now to be
like hey man mutant and then later on
they'll be like hey man everyone else
and she'll take a backseat but based on
how [ __ ] charming
that actor is um
they could literally make her
or
miss marvel if they were going to make
her an x-men like the kitty pride or
[ __ ] jubilee like the youthful way
into
something like you know the way peter
parker was the kind of a in the movies
you know a protege of iron man if you
will if they were doing something like
that then there's no chance that she
would get discarded or something that
she'd become a main feature and also not
every mutant needs to be an x-man maybe
she doesn't want to go to that janky
school
maybe she's perfectly happy she's like i
live in jersey city why would i want to
go to connecticut
garbage the schwarm is awful in
connecticut
i don't know if it is i'm just [ __ ]
with connecticut um
and also like we've seen the inhumans
nobody wants to be the star the in
humans
yeah
we four whole episodes of that and we're
done yeah
so
yeah gee let her be a mutant mutants are
cool
so that's why
what we're being told from breaking news
ladies and gentlemen from the front row
uh the reason that she was an inhuman in
the comics is because marvel's like no
more [ __ ] mutants like wanda they
were like no more mutants they just
didn't want to create new so they were
like let's shift her over to the
inhumans instead
so it's a return
i'll take it yeah i'll take that um
but i absolutely love the show i
i can't pay it any higher compliment
than i'm watching it again oh it was so
charming and dazzling so well shot it's
crazy my whole life i really didn't
notice
direction probably because i had none
myself and
now more than ever i noticed like really
wonderful direction and that show every
episode was composed incredibly well
um just is shot and cut together
incredibly well and then you've got like
some incred
fun characters that you want to live
with you want to know more about i just
absolutely adored it i know i get
[ __ ]
beat up online because like you like
everything but i really loved this i
thought it was so [ __ ] beautiful and
going into it i was like i'm sure i'll
watch it but like it was kind of like
obi-wan kenobi when they announced that
i was like
i mean i guess but i don't give a [ __ ]
about him and [ __ ] and then i watched
the show and i was like all i care about
is obi-wan kenobi it's the same thing
with ms marvel when they announced it i
was like i'm sure i'll watch it i
already paid for disney plus [ __ ]
free and [ __ ] but then as i watched it
they really captured my imagination my
heart like is incredibly well done what
did you think
uh yeah
i mean here's the thing
usually we disagree to a certain
extent yeah but i i was riding for ms
marvel very early on like the first
episode i thought was really charming
but then once you get deeper into her
what she wants what she's looking for
her emotional journey and then the
cultural
sort of exploration like i found it all
just fascinating and the ending felt a
little small to me
in that we're just gonna have a fight in
a high school gym when we had previously
gone to karachi yeah you know like i
mean that's why they're like look we
spent all the money going to karachi
like which apparently last episode we're
gonna have one of those x-men fight in a
gift shop at the statue of liberty
things
yeah precisely you know what happens to
a frog when it gets hit by lightning
the same thing that happens to
everything else
what happens to a movie when they run
out of money they shoot in the gift shop
at the end
um so yeah it felt a little small but at
least it was okay with them ending at
the high school because it brought home
like oh these are kids and the notion of
like the government
going in there with sonic weapons and
[ __ ] trying to blast kids like
they've had to put up a warning at the
beginning of the episode where they were
like you know trigger warning that
there's some [ __ ] you may find sensitive
there's guns being fired at children
yeah which is you know
yikes but they handled incredibly well i
i like that it ended in the school and i
liked that it wasn't like we got to save
the universe it's like we just got to
save these people right here because the
stakes become emotional and not physical
it's not about
maybe [ __ ] thanos does that thing and
can i we can we talked about the fact
that how ridiculous it is that in thor
um that new one that there's a suddenly
an eternity where you can go and ask a
wish and i wish his granted but thanos
never is like i'm gonna just go to
[ __ ] this dude and ask a wish and i
can get all these things i can just make
everybody disappear with a wish
did you just [ __ ] jump out of mystery
i just jumped out shade and [ __ ] thor
week two shade on thor which i have seen
three times and it uh it doesn't get
better
i mean it's like again it's not a bad
time at the movies but none of it makes
sense really
that's all
just drive by on four it really was
um
all right wait back to ms marvel
activist marvel um
and so yeah ms marvel is done we don't
get more marvel
tv
until well we get i am groot the
animated shorts on august 10th oh oh on
disney plus yeah she-hulk on august 17th
which tomorrow they're supposed to or
saturday i guess they'll show us
something there's a 1-800 no it wasn't a
1-800 number you can call they passed
out yeah they passed out these flyers
that
like you could call 1-800 she-hulk or
something like that and there's a
pre-recorded message that is it like a
porn line yes
that's how they're selling the show on
disney plus
you know what'll work blow jobs
it's uh her you know going like are you
an asgardian who burns lawns when you
leave and [ __ ] like that so it's a
series of like uh inside jokes and stuff
but i thought that was cool like kind of
old school analog to be like hey here's
a phone number
call that most of the new generation be
like what are those
talk to a person what the [ __ ] talk to a
person so yeah there's still a bunch of
marvel tv coming you know what if season
two will come sometime this year the
guardians holiday special
at the holidays
echo sometime next year i think which is
going to have daredevil and kingpin in
it indeed and then we have a bunch of
[ __ ] that they haven't dated yet there's
agatha house of darkness armor wars
daredevil ironheart loki season two
marvel zombies secret invasion and
whatever the world of wakanda show
they're doing
is
um so we're bound to get some of this
information on saturday however not all
of it because what's the disney event
that's coming up e23 is in september so
naturally they'll hold some [ __ ] for
there wholesome [ __ ] for there and
they've also got a disney investor day
in november i think like
late fall where they will then come out
and swing their dick around and tell
people like no you got to buy this stock
why because here's the billion dollars
we're going to make on x thing that we
don't even know anything about
fair enough the big news that's supposed
to happen too i saw yesterday was uh
marvel's gonna be confirming that
they're working on a movie called the
mutants
which a lot of people feel is their
first x-men movie
uh the original name for the x-men book
from courtney stanley was the mutants so
it could be them going like look they've
said x-men a zillion times in movies
maybe we'll just do this instead
and also there is the version of and i
think we talked about this a couple
years ago
that x-men is not necessarily the best
name for a thing given that half of them
are not men true um
just saying
half of people are not men
but they get all the shine why
can you explain the patriarchy to me
kevin no
no
not at all i just know i'm not a part of
it
smart yeah thanks that's how you survive
the culling exactly
um should we talk about some news [ __ ]
yeah man let's dive into the news you
want to switch places before we do the
news is it really bothering you it's not
bothering me at all but
it bothers [ __ ] the internet's still
upset
uh
not as they're growing
growing on them maybe we'll switch when
we get to scum and villainy again fair
enough we just keep [ __ ] with them
let's see if we can live with this yeah
well but you're gonna have to sign a
bunch of [ __ ] over me
all right we should move all right then
hold on let me get my things
i have all of my things
with my stories
would you like this mic or should i take
this mic with nothing
i'll say while you guys are switching
comic con
i walked the floor today and everybody
had their mask on
and last month i was at star wars
celebration and nobody was wearing a
mask so props to san diego comic-con for
and the attendees for doing what they
were asked
[Applause]
yeah they were very clear before anyone
even got here that like they're going to
make everyone wear masks and they're
going to be that you know you gotta get
in with this band and stuff like that so
good for them for looking out for us at
this point um because we can't be
trusted
to look out for our [ __ ] selves like
soon as you like everyone comes in with
masks and [ __ ] and then when you start
talking to people and they're like i
can't hear you people like [ __ ] they
pull the mask down and [ __ ] so it's nice
that there's someone looking out for us
at this point since we can't be trusted
to look out for ourselves not at all
what am i doing with this
they wanted you to sign it as well they
said mark
you're in the movie too can i write a
shopping list on it i am in the movie
you are
nice of you to remember
i am
um uh so yes the news
hey so you know what is happening that
has not happened in like 40 years tell
me kurt russell is doing a tv show
is he he is
you know the tv show he's going to be in
[ __ ] godzilla
are you serious yeah i think he's going
to go into that that was an apple tv
show yeah the apple tv legendary show
that uh where's that oh man no it's
apple tv why is it there as opposed to
like hbmx didn't they do king kong or
something um
hbo well one now well yeah warner
brothers had the the godzilla versus
kong movie but i guess they were just
not buying a tv show fair enough kurt
russell and wyatt russell oh [ __ ]
are gonna be in this [ __ ] godzilla
that's adorable it is
don't know yet what they're playing they
could be playing father and son stretch
uh they could be playing
um the same character and alternate
timelines or ultimate eras oh that would
be clever that's cute you know so like
wyatt is playing 1970s kurt russell and
kurt russell was playing 2020s kurt
russell
i lost that [ __ ] right evans yes yeah
the one of the last tv roles that kurt
russell had was a 1977 on hawaii 5-0 is
that right he also played elvis in the
john carpenter movie right he did
wasn't it quite a tv show though that's
true good point yeah
um
and our boy and we should stop calling
him a boy uh matthew shakman from one
division yeah matt jackman jackman is
directing the first two episodes [ __ ]
hey man how do you get that job why does
nobody call me for [ __ ] man
they're like you direct that kevin smith
[ __ ] man that's what you good for
because you keep saying in public we
should get somebody else
they should man
that's why stop doing it it's true fair
enough all right um
elsewhere
dune pot dude yeah have started shooting
dude
they
dude
uh yes a startup production so
thankfully it is coming to us um
pre-thanksgiving next year who have they
added to the cast this time around uh
let's see we have florence pugh
leah
christopher [ __ ] walking
elvis
and somebody's name i can't pronounce
austin butler
oh i was like
they got [ __ ] elvis for this picture
um austin butler's gonna be in it elvis
himself alice himself um that's
joining a bunch of returning cast
members like timothy chalamez and dia
rebecca ferguson josh brolin day batista
charlotte rampling son skarsgard javier
bardem
and stephen mckinley henderson
[ __ ] mordoon give it to me now i'm sorry
did i just get loud and hot about zoom
it's that [ __ ] tequila lunch coming
back yo
feel no froggy i might as well jump um
but a person who is not in a movie that
we are looking forward to is daniel
kaluuya who is not returning for black
panther 2.
his character's not his character is not
and neither is the actor i guess that
would stand a reason uh why because he
was working on nope
yeah all right moving on man
that was it he was working on nope right
yeah so he would have come back if he
wasn't he would have come back although
to be fair wakabi was probably in prison
that's a
mental revolution that got quashed and
that's what happens to
insurrectionists they go to jail
oh mark you must be watching television
or something you and your movies
um yeah i asked my wife i was like you
come watch fat man beyond she goes [ __ ]
you the government
because right now they were doing the
the hearing they did a prime time
version of the january 6 hearing so she
was way more interested in that than
this i mean fair i guess fair enough
apologies to all of you could be seeing
the fall of a republic
uh more black mirror is coming did you
know they were making more black mirror
yeah but i i knew they were eventually
going to uh he does most of the writing
and stuff so we're kind of you got to
wait for him to let the genius pile up
charlie but uh they talked about it i
remember
like
you know it was a year ago or two years
ago he said something where he was just
like
the world is way worse than black mirror
i'm gonna wait a minute [ __ ] so i think
he figures that things are getting back
to normal it's time to horrify everybody
again uh one of the greatest [ __ ]
television shows ever produced i mean
does it count as a television show if
it's a streamer it does um if for no
other reason than some brilliant
storytelling um you know even the stuff
that's not horrifying they got two
pretty emotional episodes san junipero
and uh does it hang the dj or i forget
what the other one's called beautiful
but man oh man this was the show that
made the british pm [ __ ] a pig
like an amazing episode of television
which like sounds immature but when you
watch it you're like that is what would
happen like
that yeah you'd have no choice uh so
yeah they've they've announced a bunch
of cast members for season six
but and you know it's like zazie bates
um josh hartnett aaron paul kate mara
um kevin kevin smith on that list uh did
not see kevin smith no i'm sorry
um the thing that's troubling though
is that
it's unclear if charlie brooker
is returning to the show what
yeah no he's the mastermind he is the
mastermind indeed but it's been lim it's
been in limbo for three years since
season five aired mostly due to
production companies changing hands over
the past three years
and he is currently slated to produce
something else for netflix and his
production companies apparently not
he left one company started another one
so just it's unresolved whether he is
going to be the one continuing the
stories of black mirror i mean i would
consider him a key man like
that show is him he is that show i
interviewed him at the new york comic
con once lovely dude but yeah that's
he's very much without that dude the
author of that thing
um well that's a bummer i mean but
no that's a bummer i was gonna say well
at least we're getting black mirror but
is it black mirror if it's not charlie
indeed i didn't mean to break your heart
that quickly but hey there's gonna be
more powerpuff girls though
well i only care if craig mccracken's
doing it he is indeed yes
we did it you guys i met him years ago
during the first incarnation of the
powerpuff girls lovely dude and i loved
that show that was right like my kid was
young so i had a good excuse to be like
oh we watch it for her but i loved that
show it was absolutely phenomenal yeah
so he's rebooting it it's expanding the
upon the world of blossom and bubbles
and buttercup who face off on a variety
of villains composed of familiar faces
and new threats um in addition to that
he's also re-imagining or rebooting
foster's home for imaginary friends also
his show yeah yeah another great show
um apparently the cw is still working on
the live-action reboot of the cartoon
the one that they were like we're not
doing that one yeah the diablo cody
written version that uh
that they ran
was that diana cody wrote that yeah wow
so apparently there's gonna be lots more
powerpuff girls in our future
you know what else is in our future on
disney plus tell me
dirty stuff
what do you mean they're going to do
that one and two and logan are
premiering on disney plus tomorrow
are they putting them in a special
category
no
just dirty [ __ ] on main is what they're
doing dirty [ __ ] on me
they're not even sliding the dms they're
just [ __ ] like look it's that dude's
dick
it's
sodomy
um well that's a good sign that means
there must be like we got to get them
used to the idea that disney will be
dealing with deadpool because that'll be
next and so deadpool 3 which they've
guaranteed us is going to be just as
filthy as the other two deadpools
this is a little bit of a heating the
water so that we're all not freaked out
um i i think most people can handle
grown-up disney by this point i don't
think anyone's going to be like
[ __ ]
at the panel what we that i did with
shatner
he said [ __ ] i was like oh my god
hearing you say [ __ ] was great and he
goes i say [ __ ] all the time
and then he proceeded to do a litany of
[ __ ] and then at one point somebody was
like why don't you guys have a curse off
and [ __ ] and so [ __ ] from star trek
he pulled out double dumbass on you
it was pretty sweet and then he out
cursed me man i [ __ ] instantly [ __ ]
can you believe it what i shrank in the
face of [ __ ] captain kirk i was like
he knows everything
the [ __ ] like pulled out the
kobayashi maru on me and [ __ ] he was
just
you're so good at it it was good i was
hoping you guys would have done a
two-man rendition of that scene from the
wire
remember the scene season one episode
like five where they walk into a crime
scene it's bunk and mcnulty and the only
word they utter for four minutes is [ __ ]
oh yeah i remember that scene was like
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] mother [ __ ] a [ __ ]
like tracing the gunshots and like move
in the fridge like [ __ ] me i remember
the [ __ ] so i would have loved that can
you do that can you call bill and just
do that for me i will make a short film
just for you thank you you just put on
my voicemail and i'll just play that
when i get sad done and done um we have
two more pieces of news one of them is
weird
and the other one is sad
the weird one
is that director joe dante
is of the firm belief joe dante who
directed such classics as
gremlins
yes um
uh inner space
indeed did uh did he do honey i shocked
the kids as well no no i think that's
chris columbus
no that's definitely not chris columbus
no um i mean but joe dante's done a
bunch and a very storied career in some
of the the best 80s movies
uh of an era indeed he is positively
convinced that star wars ripped off
gremlins for baby yoda
i don't
i mean they're both small
here's his quote if i remember correctly
wait baby yoda is just yoda
small but not but not yoda but like the
species so once you got a yoda
if you young him up
he would only his analogy works if
they had a gremlin who was [ __ ] six
foot tall
and then they made gremlins and made him
small and [ __ ] but yoda
was a thing and then they just made them
little and if i remember correctly yoda
happened before the gremlins happened
yes um so according to joe dante who
told the san francisco chronicle
i think the longevity of the films is
really key to this one character gizmo
who is essentially like a baby
which brings me of course to the subject
of baby yoda i'm not sure how that's
enough i was gonna say how does one make
that instant connection he's like which
brings me of course to baby yoda i would
have never been there but brings him of
course to baby oda who is completely
stolen and is just out and out copied
shamelessly i would think
oh he's got thoughts
wow he said that in a major newspaper
not even to somebody online he said it
out loud wow
like bam just himself
here is a star wars story you better
have an opinion uh i'm not gonna say
that i know anything about paying homage
to a space opera
but i think joe dante's full of [ __ ]
wow
that was very measured
explain i mean
you know
they got both got big ears gizmo like
look if if you couldn't feed baby yoda
after midnight there'd be a problem
if you couldn't get him wet there'd be a
problem but i think they're pretty safe
agreed i didn't see it myself and i have
nothing but respect for
joe dante but i was like oh that's a
stretch that's like me [ __ ] going
like
you know hey man did you ever see the
[ __ ] uh the bear
no not the bear was the movie the bear
was the movie with [ __ ] leonardo
dicaprio where bear tries to eat him
yeah
revenant yeah that would be the bear i
preferred about the bear that would be
like me going hey man did you ever see
the revenant they stole that from jay
and silent bob strike back because
there's bears in it yeah
they did
so yeah joe dante
is uh in his own private idaho i suppose
having feelings about grogu
that are unclear it's i'm the only thing
that bums me out about this i'm sad that
he doesn't get to enjoy baby ota like
the rest of us because he looks at baby
yoda you don't see baby yoda he's he's
the maguire yeah he sees a shaved gizmo
so the rest of the world is like we
[ __ ] love baby oda saved us from the
brink of extinction and he's the one guy
that's like man
they stole that [ __ ] you just hate
watching it over and over and over again
and it's like darkened rooms like
[ __ ] there it is right there
look at him look at you
look he left luke skywalker to be with
his friend and joe dante's like i
[ __ ] hate this show
roll it back i want to watch it again
give me my [ __ ] money
uh he joe dante has done an incredible
bodywork so he's more than entitled to
his opinion but i honestly don't see it
especially when yoda came first anyway
um
but you know not everything that just
went
small is stolen from
[ __ ] gremlins
otherwise you could say like my dick was
stolen from gremlins as well
do you feed it after midnight
i try
can't get it wet though no matter how
hard i try
uh and our last piece of news is uh is
the sad one and it's again we have
covered stories like this on a
frequency that had hitherto before
been been remarkable the the passing of
comic book legends um alan grant passed
away
today at 73 years old um in case you're
not familiar with alan grant he
co-wrote uh judge dredd and strontium
dog for 2008 d for almost a decade he
created the bat villains anarchy the rat
catcher ventriloquist mr zazz he created
mr zazz victor zazz you know he wrote
detective comics uh a couple of amazing
runs with norm breifogel on art
i discovered him discovered him he's my
fault i [ __ ] pull him out of nowhere
i encountered him first when he wrote a
batman judgment crossover called
judgement in gotham he wrote a fantastic
run on lobo with simon bisley doing the
art
and if all of this wasn't enough to
hallow this dude in the comic book hall
of fame
he discovered alan moore
how
he fished a script out of the
unsolicited submissions pile at 2000 a.d
and i was like i think maybe that kid
could write some comics
and wow he was right
um
you know it's unclear 73 years old might
have seemed uh old 50 years ago but now
if shatner can be 91 and still [ __ ]
kicking 73
is uh it's too young to go
especially for a dude who just seemed to
love writing comic books and love and
wrote some of the most remarkable ones
that we've seen in in many a day um his
run on detective with norm bryfogl was
one of my all-time favorite
batman runs not just for like you know
mr zazz and stuff like that although
which was a fantastic character when
they first introduced the notion of like
this serial killer marks his body for
every [ __ ] kill it was like one of
the most metal things i'd ever read in a
batman comic but those two
created so much joy for me in the
stories that they told i loved alan
grant's storytelling and i loved uh bry
fogel's art when he depicted what allen
wrote man that's a big loss um
he's a hell of a writer
um [ __ ] and that just makes me feel
very old when your heroes start dropping
i don't know i guess i should be
thinking about him instead of thinking
about me
i'm like god if he's dead i must be
really old
um what a legend let's give it up for
the great alan grant ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
uh is that all the news that's fit to
print that's all the news i copied and
pasted from the internet give it up for
mark he'd give you the news ladies and
gentlemen he gave me the news
[Music]
[Applause]
uh okay um we don't have a second
sponsor right
we do not no no we're just about dicks
today
there it is yes so remember our first
sponsor and only sponsor of the night
blue chew ladies and gentlemen gives you
a little extra [ __ ] something
just not not words um
shall we
dive into the q and a but i can do it
man
it came all this way it's true all right
so uh ladies and gentlemen you know we
always kind of get to this point of the
show where we open it up to the audience
and uh we do q a do we have prizes to
give out we do uh brett deacon dropped
off some 4dx tickets uh our good friend
brett deacon who works at 4dx and
screenx so he's giving us tickets and
then um
somebody gentle giant or somebody sent
me a whole box of
really cool mandalorian stuff
and the people who received it at the
bar lost the note so i'm not quite sure
who it's actually from
but uh props to whoever sent it gentle
giant mandalorian bookends and they're
pretty heavy
so we got some good stuff [ __ ] all
right so we got prizes kids if your
question gets picked and you ask the
question you could walk away with uh 40x
tickets you could walk away with
um
mandalorian uh mythosaur bookends
that's right can i have him
i'm just i just want [ __ ]
free [ __ ] because it's comic-con you're
like
this bag you just gave me take that swag
back
um all right so there it is man we're
gonna leave uh jc of course to pick the
folks
um
and uh
that way we don't get in trouble later
on me and mark don't get yelled at
uh who do we got j.c i'm handing the mic
over to this guy right here
matt
give it up for matt man
[Applause]
looks very familiar yeah it it it's uh
expensive to look this silly
tell me about it
um that's awesome man i've uh i've
over the years of course i've seen a lot
of silent bob and then when i wore the
hockey jerseys i saw people do that
the purple jacket silent uh kevin smith
is a new one but it's [ __ ] on point i
was hoping you would wear it today too
but i i probably am going to wear it
tomorrow okay today was since i was kind
of doing the panels i wore this i'm
gonna get the
photo op with you in comic con the
clerk's thing what is it 1 30 tomorrow
what oh when we go to the booth yeah
yeah yeah me and a bunch of us from the
movie are going to the lions gate booth
in separate shifts i think i go by
myself at like 1 30. i'll be there take
pictures behind the counter
you know if you have a mask on then it's
like half a picture that's true i'll
probably have my mask off to be honest
with you i just said
i'll pull it down to you know to show
off it sounded dirtier than i meant to i
really did once you were like i'll pull
it down i was like you better pull it
hard yeah yeah
all right ask away yes you two are so
cute so this is a little little morbid
but if you guys
knew you were going to uh
leave this mortal coil what would your
last meal be and
and it could be anything from like your
grandma's favorite dish to like your
favorite restaurant what would your what
would your like if you could have five
courses what would your last meal be on
earth if you could have it number one i
love this question thank you uh number
two i'm really gonna put some thought
into it because i didn't think about
like when you brought up it was
something you could have been something
your grandmother made i'm like holy [ __ ]
so what does that mean like even though
my grandmother's dead they gotta bring
her back from the dead yeah or someone
knows how to make it exactly worth it
alone just to see my grandma again man
yeah be like oh my god let me tell you
what's happened like let me say this to
you clerks like you know she missed all
that [ __ ]
but they would still make you your
favorite food or something yeah
all right let me think
it's weird because like on one level
you'd imagine and be like oh eat
something non-vegan because you're vegan
now and you're gonna die tomorrow and
you're gonna die tomorrow yeah so you
might as well take an animal out with
you right exactly
um
i don't think there's no meat that i
miss i don't miss anything that i'm like
oh i used to eat that now i don't but
i'm telling you you captured my
imagination with the grandma thing
because right then and there i was like
i hadn't thought about sentimental or
nostalgic eating or eating to bring back
a piece of the past like that [ __ ]
ratatouille eating
when he eats and he [ __ ] becomes a
little boy and [ __ ] like that give me
that ratatouille [ __ ] yeah some of that
ratatouille eating so my ratatouille
eating moment i think would probably be
i'd ask for
i'd ask for my grandmother's um
dumplings she made dumplings but not
like normal
dumplings like if you get them at like a
chinese food place where there's stuff
wrapped up in a little like a ravioli
these were just globs of [ __ ] dough
and she'd boil them and she's chicken
and dumpling southern kind of like that
very much like that but she was like she
come from polish stock so she always
maintained it was a polish dish and then
one day i went down to the south like
your grandmother was [ __ ] lying bro
but i would you know
i haven't had that since like not since
she passed away she lost her sight
before she passed away so for the last
14 16 years of her life she couldn't do
any of the things she enjoyed doing
which included [ __ ] cooking and stuff
so it wouldn't only be like oh my god my
grandma has been dead for a few years so
i haven't had these this would go even
further back like right into like the
[ __ ] heart the crotch of my childhood
if you will so i'm gonna say that sounds
problematic a little bit especially with
grandma being involved i'm gonna say
that i'm gonna say grandma's dumplings
man they were pretty magical
good question what about you captain
um i don't go as far back as my
grandmother but
i remember when i moved out of my my the
parental home
my mother gave me a she made a cookbook
and so in this cookbook and it was a
thing she just made on a [ __ ]
photocopying machine there were no
drawings sadly it was like mom come on
step up your game
but your graphic presentation is weak
mother i mean even word has enough
[ __ ] [ __ ] clip art you got to put
in here to dazzle it up but it was like
this 10-page cookbook of all the things
that she used to make for me
that i would then be able to now cook on
my own that is adorable
i've never made anything out of that
football you are an animal
um
mostly because
my mother thankfully is still alive and
while she is still alive she can do it i
would rather she do this than me [ __ ]
these things up what i hear is you're
just be the note behind the notice
you're incredibly lazy
i mean sometimes
um but there's a thing that she used to
make and it doesn't even really have a
name but it's it's based on rice and
beans rice and beans was i love rice and
beans what kind of beans these were um
black-eyed peas you're picking a vegan
dish no because what she would then do
you should make a big pot of [ __ ]
like rice and peas rice and beans and
then she would take whatever meat had
been left over over the course of the
week and just throw it in there and so
it was always this like
it was a like mom's working late and it
doesn't take a lot to cook a [ __ ]
bowl of rice and it doesn't take much to
do this but it was this kind of like
climactic meal of a week that had gone
by that she made even though she was
busy and tired but had to put something
on the table that she knew that was good
for us and she cared and all that stuff
i haven't had that particular dish in 30
years
i would want that because like
i'm not gonna make it my wife is she's
not that person
um she has made a couple of other red my
mom makes a great [ __ ] ham sorry kev
um
which we'll have for easter but like
that particular thing i haven't had
since i was a kid and that's the thing
that i would want before somebody kicks
me off of this mortal coil awesome thank
you
excellent [ __ ] question man more like
brisket
from austin maybe um you get to grab
some uh ticks
thank you and give it up for him as a
hell of a question thank you sir
[Applause]
thank you all right
jc
bring us another victim if you will
howdy hi guys what's your name oh it's
jabilani
jabalani everyone give it up for job
alone
um so i wrote this down because i don't
want to mess it up first off welcome
back to san diego thank you um
i've been a fan since 94. fans 94 kevin
thank you fans in static shock i don't
remember the year but
that's that's
fair enough
so um
congrats on the izer nomination and with
that is the vein of my question
so given that awards are named after
living people real world people who uh
for their accomplishments their
personalities are achievements
i wanted to know given the opportunity
to name award for your co-host
what would that award be for
and how would you describe the
actual award and if jc could then give
it to both of you
all right so i got to come up with the
kevin smith the smithy's the smith
the kevin's the smitty's
um
i think it would be an award
for longevity
it's it's a career in the bedroom in the
bedroom brought to you by blue chew you
guys
um
no it's ultimate it's a lifetime
achievement award it's a the person who
has over time
displayed a commitment to his craft and
more than that a commitment to the
audience who receives that craft because
i've never met a person who does this
job who loves his audience more than
kevin does i've never met a person who
engages with his audience as often and
as substantially as kevin i mean we're
here i mean we're all [ __ ] here
and so the the ability to stay connected
not just to where he came from and not
just to the fan inside of everybody but
to make that an integral part of the way
he does business and the way he makes
movies and the way that he conducts
himself in the world and not enough
people do that
not enough people can demonstrate that
level of affinity for the people for
whom they share the planet with and
share his art with and so yeah i would
give the smitty's to somebody who just
loves doing the job that he does and
loves the people he does the job for any
design for the award
uh i mean it's a it's a it's a brass
plated baseball cap
[Laughter]
i think blunt was easy but i'm sure
there's blunties
if you have not already sold blunties as
a trademark
um i think that was nice my award for
mark is definitely a writing award
um but let's narrow it down because they
give out plenty writing awards
this is a writing award that you give to
a writer to an author to a creator
that has created
five or more things that make you go
[ __ ] i wish i had done that
um it's a very specific award that only
certain writers could win but he would
absolutely
uh
be the first recipient and then the
reward would be named after him we would
call it the bernies
and um it would be shaped like a dick
just because it would have a secondary
use other than just being a trophy and
[ __ ] i don't know jc if you want to
bring dance man what do you got
um well mark's
kind of stole mine i thought uh
commitment to wearing backwards baseball
hats yes where like i'll tell you like
ken griffey jr might get the first one
and then on so on and so forth i laughed
even though i don't understand that
reference the three sports people yeah
and then for mark i would do
cheeseburgers best cheeseburger of the
year because during the pandemic he did
his cheeseburger competition he did the
run that's right i do miss that
fond memories of swimming in greece
but at the time like i was captivated by
his
his
instagram the clothes
sport
he found a way to make the pandemic work
for him
not for my heart though
no not at all
speaking of which did anyone get any
food tonight at movies after dark
[Music]
food has been absolutely wonderful the
volks of the tin roof have been so
phenomenal give them a round of applause
if you like their food kids
um this am i meant to sign this
this is amazing remember like [ __ ]
wrestling buddy pillows and [ __ ]
this is
called big shots and it's a silent bob
one but i don't know if i'm meant to
sign it or i'm meant to show people like
buy this [ __ ] thing
but who buy this [ __ ] thing
we take it to bed with you and [ __ ] like
this
it's like a little kamiko yeah
but i'll sign it anyway just in case
uh okay we got another did you get
tickets did you grab your tickets well
done give it up for him that's a
wonderful question
hello hello what's your name holly hi
holly hi i have a two-part question okay
how are you yes
yes mr from ask your universe would you
like to have its own series
which character from the viewers
universe would i like to have their own
series
i mean selfishly i should say jay and
silent bob
because then i'll be working a lot but
one of my favorite characters uh in the
world that i've ever created was uh
randall so i would love to
watch a randall show which is
essentially like watching a clerk's show
which i you know now at this point in my
life i regret
not
doing we did a clerk's cartoon and [ __ ]
but i love those characters so much like
when we were rehearsing on clerks three
like i remember saying [ __ ] man i wish
we were making clerks nine
like why is this only the third one i
love these characters and [ __ ] so i'd
probably go right back to quick stop
most of the stories i tell
emanate from quick stop anyway they're
all derivations of clerks to some degree
they all kind of spin off from there
except tusk
but um i think that's what i would do i
think i would go with randall and
randall and by default dante as well
okay
mark
you got to write the movie oh okay or
the series
how would you kill him off
[Music]
i think it would be like you know how in
pacific rim there's the uh the the rift
at the bottom of the pacific ocean that
won't ever seal and keeps getting bigger
and bigger and bigger
anal fissure
this motherfucker's ass just prolapses
and turns inside itself and just
yeah now it'll be great it'll be awesome
it's a hot way to die
the hottest way to do it yes
uh anal prolapse death i didn't see that
coming i'm taking that writing award
away from you
see you never see it coming because it
comes from behind that's true oh [ __ ]
so sexy uh give it up for that's a great
question these tickets are yours
thank you
all right we could do one more for the
mandalorian bookends or we could vote on
favorite questions
wow damn sounds like vote
somebody said one guy said one more
one guy yelled hope
rebellions i feel you i feel you on that
one
um
i
[Music]
here let's do round of applause how many
people think we give it out based on the
three questions we already heard put
your hands together
[Applause]
[Music]
and now how many people will say just do
one more question and give it to that
person
one more question
democracy wins yet again
what's your name captain hello my name
is jesse campbell and we'll give it up
for jesse hey jessie campbell
jesse you have a chance to win these
amazing mandalorian bookends or this
amazing man is it is it plural or
singular if it's a book ends his book
ends with an s
so sin plural
yeah i'm just reading man fair enough um
all right here's your chance
to walk away with some sweet ass
swag from jc himself proprietor of scum
and villainy that guy hopes she wins he
doesn't want you to let him down
give me your all-star cast for the
supreme
court wow
you just earned the bookends man
[Music]
um all right this is i'm gonna show my
ignorance how many people on the supreme
court
uh
nine nine i get nine
and they're and and any judges i want
do they have to be judges
well
they have to be wizard at least okay so
they have to be playing actual people
who are judges or could i just pick nine
[ __ ] who would be great on the
supreme court
and i'm [ __ ] do they can
they can be fictional characters too
right that is correct number one batman
there's a [ __ ] knows about
justice right there
number two
batman no um
let me see
yes no robin's soft on crime
uh batman gandalf
hell shall not pass
yes exactly um let's see obi-wan kenobi
[Music]
um
the president from battle star galactica
rosalind rosalind carter
is that her name carter no that was a
singer
laura ross laura rosalin
um
not never jay no
the victor carver the actual human
person victor carter um hold on all
right so how many do i have so far
i'm at four and i get nine five more
five more all right nobody say [ __ ] i'm
the thing
fletch
he's always real smart in them books
bugs bunny
one of the most clever [ __ ]
ever existed
sees right through the [ __ ] could cut
right through it seems
seems kind of
my kind of rabbit
how many more do i get
three more
um let me see [ __ ] that quick rabbit i
like bugs
i can literally not think of another
rabbit
who is
oh oh no
jack creature
[ __ ] yes jack reacher not jack reacher
just reach her just reach her yeah yeah
because if it's jack reacher then tom
cruise shows up and nobody wants that
i'm talking about [ __ ] reacher man he
curbs you to death and he's like justice
all right how many more i get
i feel like i'm very male heavy
shouldn't i bring more women into laura
roslin you know [ __ ] princess leia of
course
i get one more lady
i was gonna say sorceress i i should
kind of stay on brand and [ __ ]
alanis morrison is god there's my last
judge
well done
[Applause]
that is my supreme court man and
ironically they all hate abortion no
they would do justice you
it's a hard act to follow kevin
i mean but it's like the sky's the limit
i know what you love with batman dude
you can take batman as well batman's
just a common sense answer all right
okay i got i got a plan okay i'm
sticking with his plan
tina turner
chaka khan
aretha
franklin mary wells oh my god i want to
go to the supreme court concert um
donna summer oh
excellent [ __ ] choice man thank you
thank you
i'm stateless diana ross is the supreme
she's the head justice she's the chief
justice
of the supreme court the supreme court
yes
[Music]
they run the world um
cardi b
nice keeping it fresh keeping it young
beyonce
oh of course
um
big mama thornton i got left
one more left did we count did we
already count uh diana ross
gladys [ __ ] knight because here's why
nobody understands injustice like black
lady
you've been singers
over by everybody that has ever been on
the planet
and so i want the supremes court
who's got no [ __ ] time for your
[ __ ]
give it up for mark's answer ladies
thank you very much give it up for that
great question
he did you proud you buddy
go read some books to put in between the
book and
oh my god that was delightful what about
you bam man you got nine
oh gosh
[Music]
what a great call who said that
and [ __ ] well done andrew i got that
felt like family feud when they say the
answer and everybody's like judge dredd
what do you keep
in the house in case a party breaks out
judge dredd
i was going to say my two
i think you have to put charles xavier
on the supreme court excellent [ __ ]
call and uh oh my god he would know if
they were guilty or not
and daredevil right and uh you can
listen to their [ __ ] heartbeat
there's another great one [ __ ] i thought
adora
you know
and you're adorable yeah that's fine
she's terrible we don't want it
it is a lifetime appointment though
that's true she could serve her like 80
years yeah like where's dookiehouser
[ __ ]
can just show up and run [ __ ]
oh i've still got to keep going yeah
okay
uh wonder woman she's got the lasso of
truth
god that's [ __ ] good man that's good
yes i like your supreme court uh what am
i at xavier
shira wonder woman
the race hair would look good
um
man no
i mean yeah yeah i won't put jar jar on
the supreme court
every court needs a jester
right poor jar jar get blamed for every
bad decision whether it was his fault or
not [ __ ] you're you're like lisa said no
he was lisa was the dissenting opinion
oh who else we got
[Applause]
kinky kelly yeah mr spock would be good
on the supreme court he's logical
uh lionel lord of the thundercats wow
good call very noble um
george [ __ ] carlin absolutely the
smartest fans
i ever met my entire life chief justice
carlin indeed
i feel like gene graves say thanos
we saw how that went
i feel like jean grey would make a good
counterpart to uh
to charles xavier like they'd work
together very well
complement one another yeah until she
goes all dark phoenix until she
discovers that charles [ __ ] with her
brain and then blows up half the planet
yeah really good point
um [ __ ] that's my kind of question man
like i'm really now i'm gonna go home
tonight
and instead of trying to have sex with
my wife i'd be like who would be on your
supreme court
i think it could be anybody yes anybody
max shady in chat says judge harry stone
from night court oh that's a great
[ __ ] call
it's an excellent call
god this is this you know i we did a
thing right before we did this i went on
tick-tock and uh we did tick-tock live
me and jay and i talked about during the
tick tock how terrifying tick-tock is to
me because as an old man whenever i look
at it i'm profoundly [ __ ] like moved
by the amount of talented people in the
world something i've always talked about
where i've always been like hey man
everyone's got something everyone got a
story to tell and then when you slide
through tick tock you literally see it
in action and it's it's sometimes very
intimidating because i'm like these
people are telling more masterful
stories in less than two minutes
sometimes than i can do in [ __ ] 90 to
two hours and stuff um so when i was
doing the the tick tock uh before we did
this the folks that worked there were
walking me through it and stuff and when
we were all done i was like yeah it's
just i i get it but that that's for
young people that's really not for me
and they're like well it's a shame
because 150 000 people watch this and i
was like i will [ __ ] masturbate on
this
what do you mean 150 000 like yeah the
tick tock audience is big and i was like
oh my god how the [ __ ] are we not on
tick tock shouldn't we do this [ __ ]
show on tick tock
this tick tock seems to be blowing up
mark i don't know if you know this or
not i'm just i'm trying to keep my vine
account live
i don't know about your ticket
um well [ __ ] man i guess we're out of
show ladies and gentlemen have you had a
good time this evening
[Applause]
i cannot thank you enough for coming out
uh some [ __ ] thanks across the boards
man uh give it up for the tin roof in
movies after dark man
how lovely this has been our home all
day it'll be our home all uh comic-con
long we got more shows coming up
tomorrow and the day after and stuff
um thank you for uh for dr josh roush
for coming all the way down here to
shoot for us
thank you to banff man who came all the
way [ __ ] down from
[Applause]
a space-themed bar in hollywood to be
with us tonight we'll also be live
tomorrow and saturday at 4 p.m so if
you're not here you can watch online
tell them good point i would have
totally spaced on that so tomorrow and
saturday as well right yeah four four to
five p.m we're gonna be doing live
streams from here just to update any new
stories that came out real short not
like a whole show like this and stuff uh
but we're gonna do it before mark is
before you go for the award tomorrow
indeed so i will i will i will reveal on
saturday how friday night went [ __ ]
now you'll be able to tell the story
find me uh mark is up for an eisner kids
give him send them all your best wishes
and i will tell you of the glorious day
in which i did not win an eyesore um but
if you enjoyed the show ladies and
gentlemen i assure you it's because of
the guy sitting to my left give it up
for the marvelous mark bernard and
everybody
[Applause]
and that is fat man beyond for this very
special edition from [ __ ] san diego
comic con 2022 i'm kevin smith i am marc
bernardi tune in next time same fat time
same fat channel spodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith happy comic-con
everybody good night
[Applause]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith